for me it seems inevitable that
eventually you're going to be
interacting with things with your hands
we've all seen this movie Minority
Report where he's controlling these
interfaces just by you know moving like
this I think this is inevitable another
interesting application is sort of in a
dangerous environment kind of
controlling a robotic arm so the
computer would be tracking what you're
doing while you try to pick something up
with your robotic arm and moving it and
that way we're not endangering people's
lives this is a scenario where perhaps
you in front of the Xbox and the Xbox is
tracking your body so you can see my
skeleton up there but it's also tracking
my my fingers so this way I can interact
and I can point that things I can
activate menus I can interact with my
game and like in more subtle ways